he's been just a shining star all year
strowman he's really stepped up he's had
a great year closing in on almost 200
innings when he comes to the ballpark
he's ready to pitch
[Applause]
and he strikes out on the change up nito
slaps a tag on him and that's the first
out of the day strowman fanning chism
one out a little late movement and the
fish are biting oh no pun intended jesus
sanchez steps in
and since went out to left field it will
drop in front of pallar
and a base hit for jesus to keep the
first inning going
runner goes pitches low anita's throw
right on target
thomas guns down jesus sanchez to end
the inning zach thompson goes right now
this will be his 14th start this season
his first in the month of september
however where he has been used solely as
a reliever 230 pounds of zach thompson
the 2-0 nemo it's hard on the ground
fair down the first base line a base hit
he's going to roll to the corner nimo is
on his way to second base jesus sanchez
the right fielder has trouble nemo's
taking off for third relay throw won't
be made head first dive a lead off
triple for brandon nimmo just sparks the
team right there he's now tied for the
team lead with three triples that ball
was perfectly rolled toward the right
field corner straight over the first
base bag
and sanchez had to go searching for it
along the sidewall into that corner kind
of kicked it for a moment that allowed
nemo to get the extra base going all the
way to third they have scored it a
triple that's line toward the middle
base it for lindor and that'll bring a
nimmo with the game's first run
so nimmo triples landorus singles from
home one nothing new york okay the mets
are off hot there's a little slider
right there a little cutter that didn't
cut and so far mr thompson is off to an
inauspicious start
big breaking ball finds the inside
corner
and it called strike three conforto down
looking for the first out
and pete hits one through the vacant
right side for a base hit glendore will
easily go first to third alonzo didn't
get much of that but there was nobody
playing on that side of the infield and
that's the third hit of the inning for
new york
thompson not exactly stretched out to
give the marlins five tonight zach does
have a couple of strikeouts in this
first inning and there are two away
two-thirds of clean baseball earlier
this month there's a called strike three
on the outside corner as he gets three
k's in the first but the vets get a run
marlins go to their bullpen dan castano
first time we've seen dan since early
may
donnie kind of working for the matchups
well castano's got a couple of
relatively quick outs here in the second
inning
strowman it's a one hopper down to third
and alvarez throws it wide he threw it
away and strowman who wasn't even
running will be safe at first base well
he's a pitcher it's okay they got a
pitch straight takes off for second and
the throw goes into center field and
he'll go a third
how about that
marcus stroman getting a walking lead
took off long before castano came out of
his stretch
stole the bag easily and took third on
the throwing error by fortes first
career stolen base for marcus stroman
first career steal to get to second and
an e2 got him to third and nimmo with a
fly ball out to
right field
sanchez underneath it will make the
catch and the marlins
avoid big trouble there in the inning
1-1 pitch to jazz and he lays down the
punt this one up the third base line
strowman's throw is late and jazz beats
it out marlins have him on the corners
with one away jazz lays down a fantastic
punt so we've had two good bunts and a
walk and you got runners on the corners
in the middle of your lineup coming up
one two coming runner goes swinging to
miss throw from his knees by neato and
bias makes the tag
[Applause]
magician makes the tag on chisholm
caught it tagged him all in one motion
brilliant and that's how athletic he is
tremendous foot speed hand speed
baseball instincts
lindor out to center racing in sierra
makes a sliding catch in center field
spectacular play from magnarise for the
first out here in the third four to at
first with two out
that's ripped into center field of
basement for baez
so javi continues to produce the hits he
now has an 11 game hitting streak and a
20 game on bay street
that's looped into right field coming in
quickly sanchez is diving he can't make
the catch
in the score comes conforto on the third
goes by
a bloop single for vr to drive in a run
it's two nothing new york sanchez got a
bit of a late break on that ball he
could not make up as much ground as
sierra did on his play earlier in the
inning and he came up a little short
there goes vr the throw is well offline
from fortes and vr walks into second
base
rounded down to third alvarez boots it
oh boy gonna bring in another run it's
been a rough day for alvarez who made a
throwing here in the last inning and now
has a routine ground ball go off his
glove for an error that brings in baez
and makes it three nothing
fortes held on to it bat went flying the
inning is over lewin diaz round down to
first his first time up
and pitch number eight is hit a ton out
to right oh into the upper deck for
leiwan diaz
a big two-run shot and it gets the
marlins right back in the game gaining
momentum as this at bat goes on had seen
the entire arsenal well he got a hanging
splinter on the eighth pitch of this at
bat and he goes upper hank
pulled on the ground nice diving stop
alonzo he hit strowman on the move
beautifully done to retire chisholm what
is this
and a little
piggyback ride at the end quite a play
by alonso good job by strowman getting
over there and a good throw
well nice play by pete and i got no
comment on the theatrics after so one
out now pete alonso pete is single to
right and foul down
and that's it hard toward the whole base
hit
and alonso has his second head of the
night this one a scorcher by diving
alvarez for his second hit
[Music]
tour of the hole that's a base hit for
baez
so back-to-back base hits for alonso and
vias to put two men aboard in the fifth
nito the batter with the base is loaded
and two out pops one two
swing and a miss for strike three
a huge strikeout to leave the bases
loaded and keep this a one-run game and
seth lugo on the pitch for the mets as
we go to the sixth
swing and a miss and sanchez down on
strikes lugo blows a fastball by him for
the first out
again the 2-2 to fortes
and he struck him out with high heat
so luga with an impressive inning gets
the side out one two three with a couple
of strikeouts so one out and one on and
now francisco lindor
and that's driven to deep left field
forget that lindor
started this game with an rbi single and
gives the mets insurance with a two-run
homer
19th home run of the year for lindor
his second in two games
and now the mets have some breathing
room it's 5-2 new york just his fifth
home run as a right-hand batter and
there was no doubt about him and when
diaz on to try for his 31st save of the
year alvarez a comebacker and a
strikeout and he goes down swinging so
six pitches two outs for diaz one two
coming he struck him out and the ball
game is over a one two three seven for
diaz and the mets snap a five-game
losing streak as they take the opener of
the double-header from the marlins five
to two
you